never septic site within the street any
desperate situation it's very very tense
now it's pretty big an organized hit
I'm Stuart Ramsey in the Amazon
and this is hot spots tonight in this
special edition of hot spots our team's
witness environmental catastrophes on
two continents with worldwide
repercussions we joined the Rangers in
South Africa fighting for the future of
the precious Rhino these magnificent
creatures are now on the brink of
extinction and we traveled deep into the
Amazon where deforestation has reached a
new level of devastation by definition
mountains being attacked
[Music]
magnificent Kruger Park in South Africa
one of the
in the world where riders could still
wrote freely but they are under attack
my team and I
involved in the anti-poaching frontline
and met some of the heroes in the Rhino
Wars a warning that some of the viewers
may find some of our pictures
Ronna with a horn is a dead run this is
a sight that may disappear in the years
to come
they felt this was a rule they had to
tackle it like one and they had to win
it you see the sheer size of them this
big dominant horn that looks terrifying
they looked like they're the only ones
that could have survived some sort of
nuclear war some major wipe out
unbelievably strong powerful dangerous
it's an incredible animal when I first
saw a runner I was in awe of this size
and make prehistoric look it doesn't
seem like it fits in our world the fact
that it survived this long is amazing it
also has this kind of real depth of
resonance because it is so endangered
and because there are people who
actually want to kill it for bits of its
body
an incredible animal that is just being
decimated off this earth
the absolutely criminal reason why
they're being killed to the brink of
extinction is because of their horn
a thing that is actually the same as our
fingernails
that's just keratin it's not even
nutritious the demand for rhino horn or
Far East is massive people will pay
millions for this on the black market
a rhino horn could fetch sixty thousand
dollars maybe more in some countries
ingesting a rhino horn is seen as an
aphrodisiac or as seen as something that
can give you energy all of which is
absolute nonsense
over recent years that demand for rhino
horn has gone up dramatically and
poaching has gone up hugely the time
that we were in South Africa a rhino was
being killed every eight hours and I
think about every eight hours one of
these animals is being slaughtered and
there was a lot of demand from the
public to do something about it
in this frontline to save the Rhino
there are some incredible characters
amazing heroes and heroines who go that
extra mile to try and save the animal
and one of the most interesting most
charismatic bravest individuals was this
vet called William Fuld who had helped
save the life of a young female that
poachers had left for dead having
chopped off a large part of her face to
get her horns the injuries that are
fitted on these animals are crazy coming
across these animals barely alive but
still their ears twitching and still
breathing you need to tell the world
what these animals are getting through
[Music]
to him it represented the most extreme
form of Cruelty that these people can
come and take a machete to a defenseless
animal and then just leave them not even
put them out of their misery
[Music]
they managed to say one was the female
beyond all odds the Rhino has survived
[Music]
and they called her Tandy which is cause
afore love and she became a symbol of I
think of what one man essentially could
do the ton diesel our vis is nothing
short of a miracle she lost an enormous
amount of blood I would estimate over 20
liters of blood winds into that soil
around where she was lying to come
across an animal as majestic as her
honor when you find them with their
faces mutilated the way she was he had
as part of his job to go and check on
some other rhinos
The Vic needs to get in a helicopter to
dr. Reiner yes to get the right amount
of anesthetic put into the diet too much
will kill it too little at the won't
fall asleep
the clock would start and there'd be a
certain amount of time to watch this
animal weaving around as it slowly got
more drugged would it try and find a
bush to hide under and then bang it
would be out and they would have to land
quickly coordinate with their teams on
the ground who would be rushing in
because they didn't want the animal to
be tranquilized for so long okay let's
try an olive please they have to be
incredibly careful we're drilling the
horn to put a microchip in an expectant
horn tissue for DNA sampling and if you
didn't do this work what are the
consequences for a creature like this
and unless we get these poaching
statistics to come down we could lose
these animals Alex got involved with the
process of helping treat the Rhinos and
what is it so this is painful it's gonna
be inflammatory I don't mind giving that
they were giving them antibiotics to
hold it if you hold it like you're
really gonna slam into it like it don't
like that because if you don't it's not
going to go in so I'm gonna I'm going to
try and do like this give it a really
good whack and then just push I can
confirm that um a rhino skin is bloody
thick okay we need to go we're going to
the crucial parts of the operation now
where they're going to try and wake the
Rhino up so we're all having to move
back out of the way for a bit as soon as
it wakes it's not gonna be friendly we
don't want to be anywhere near it we
have to leave pretty sharpish we need to
go and when the Rhino woke up we were
running for the safety of the truck
everyone was legging it back to get out
of the way
there's a really horrific side to the
story that we're effectively there to
cover but it's rare that you get the
opportunity in our job to experience
something so wonderful
Kruger National Park is an enormous park
on the eastern edge of South Africa a
stunning stunning stunning place for
this national park is the size of Wales
it's absolutely vast and much of it is
uninhabited by humans this is what the
jobs all about I mean how good at that
just be interrupted by a couple of
elephants I've been up in a helicopter
and as as far as I can see you just see
bush it is enormous
poachers have caught what they can just
come to the Kruger and Colet Rhino the
only way to deal with that is to throw
an army at them a little better the
poachers are well-armed not only to kill
the Rhino but to fight any security
forces when we were invited to witness a
demonstration of Rangers tactics
there is quite a heightened sense of
anxiety you really do get the impression
these guys are going into battle they're
all heavily armed they've got their
trained dog with them
you can see so much more of the Krueger
and we had the privilege to see herds of
Rana just another day at the office
amazing experience to have that access
seeing places that very very few people
have ever seen the thing is you're
seeing them in their very natural
habitat and so they're running free
these are the creatures they've tried to
protect this is what motivates these
people to come out here 24 hours a day
it gives them some sort of ability to
try and track these poachers they have
so few Rangers that it's almost
impossible to protect the animals that
could be a scar
they felt this was a war and they had to
tackle it like one and they had to win
it
foot patrol is a totally different
experience you thinking am I gonna
stumble across a lion leopard you feel
very very vulnerable and they are
understandably a bit edgy this is not
easy it's great but it's very hard it's
extremely hot and in the park at the
moment there is something like 15
coaching groups operating they know that
in the back of the mind you think
there's a poacher right there with his
gun sights lined up potentially on you
it looks like a war it is a war they
will shoot at us make no mistake
so it really is a war of attrition
between the Rangers and the poachers it
really did feel a little bit like
looking for a needle in a haystack
then the haystack is huge they'll go
tracking take weapons
[Music]
and they'll use animals bombs will be
trained to tech poachers if we catch you
you're going to jail for a long time
we're now going to have a little bit of
time with the the dog training the k-9
unit they took us out on a training
session we're going along with the dog
came angry hell they're trying to track
down the poachers one of the Rangers is
pretending to be a poacher and when they
unleash those dogs they are vicious
and they were really really aggressive
these dogs more Chris have been I
expected
do you thinking oh my word I'm filming
this and I'm not too far away from these
guys well God trying to persuade me to
put on that suit protects you and I
thought that was looked foolhardy to me
but they have found it puts riders and
which is
investigation
look search the whole area for clues
that can eventually track whoever killed
this enemy I don't think we were quite
prepared for what we experienced when we
went out with the CSI Ranger unit
sad sight you couldn't see the Reiner
for the vultures the unit is made up of
specialist experienced investigators and
forensic experts it is utterly horrific
you have this magnificent huge creature
in a pool of its own blood
it's a horrible sight it was
overwhelming because the carcass had
been decomposing for a couple of days
and the sight was heart-rending gosh the
smell going hey you would expect to find
them on a murder scene or of a human
being here they are at a scene of a
rhino killing and they're trying to find
something that will lead them to the
killer or killers the Garwin put a
point-of-view camera on the lead
investigator I want the audience to
experience what our subjects are seeing
and I think the point-of-view camera
gives you that we could really get a
sense of what his job is and his focus
is and what he sees I wanted our
audience to be the eyes of the CSI
investigator if they were very focused
on finding the bullet if they find the
bullet they can then match that bullet
to the weapon that fired it then you've
got
everyone gets very squeamish about blood
and disintegration animals death
everywhere you filmed you had to do it
in a way that wasn't going to actually
show full all the gore and the horror of
the scene you want you to give that
impact this is terrible what is
happening to the Rhinos so you don't
want to desensitize it too much but I
also don't want to put people off so
it's a really delicate balance we should
not be the filter and stop people from
seeing what is real this is what happens
this is life or death you have a look at
it and you make your mind up the word
rhino is actually derived from the Greek
word for horn that is what it is
some of the parks are so concerned about
poaching
that they are willing to actually dehorn
the Rhinos themselves in a desperate
attempt to stop poachers wanting to then
kill the wine the dehorning is a little
controversial because obviously you are
completely altering the animal you're
giving it major surgery is it actually
working doing this I mean it's very
drastic so to take the horn off lots of
you won't feel that's giving in to the
poaching in some ways the other
counter-argument is this is the only
thing that's gonna stop the animal being
killed the Rhino doesn't always land in
a perfect position in the perfect place
everybody then has to try and move the
Rhino as best they can
they cover the eyes so that it's not too
scared and then they take a massive
chain sword of course it can't feel a
thing but all you're seeing is this big
chain saw just cutting off this
magnificent creatures magnificent horn
you so close to a rhino that you can
hear breathing you can smell it was
absolutely amazing I was in all of this
beautiful creature very keen to get the
job done not just for the safety of the
Rhino but to make sure they did it and
were well away by the time the Rhino
woke up you're not surrounding the
Rhinos because when the Rhino gets up
its tased it's confused if there's one
pissed-off animal there we go a Rhino
will if it sees its cover a bad eyesight
but if it sees you it will go for you
we're just moving slightly back because
the animals will revive quite quickly
you can hear the Rhino it's getting up
and moving around know when you've got a
twenty three hundred kilogram animal who
wakes up once you don't want to be in
the same area
I heard about this orphanage when I was
researching the story and it was quite
difficult place to find because they
don't want to be found and these are
preachers whose mothers have been
poached they're abandoned and they may
also have been attacked a number of
these little babies arrived in a
terrible state some of them have even
been hacked not fully horn but act by
the poacher to keep them away from being
trying to hack off the Horn of their
mothers I mean baby anything's are quite
endearing right baby rhinos who are
orphans are a whole different category
gee youth have you seen the size of
these things
there's nothing very babyish about them
at that stage except they act like
babies and they were feeding now with
milk bottles and you could hear them
squealing like they're crying for their
milk your hot mouths it's just the
cutest sound and then when they open up
their mouths to take the bottle you just
can't help yourself falling in love with
these super cute things and the place is
run by this very devoted individual
petronella
and she was like very very at home with
them we'd all be cowering at the back
next for the fences they don't know
their own strength they don't know their
own speed and they also are
unpredictable very very unpredictable
because they don't have much sense in
their head and they're still so young
but when they want to play well I mean
you got to watch out
and of course Godwin was right in there
their babies were very interesting
something what is this strange thing and
they'd be pushing their nose up against
the camera we were really close to them
they didn't mind us touching them and
stroking them feeling like we had a
connection with them and they were just
as curious about us as we were about
them look he's loving it he's closing
his eyes in satisfaction sir look Nick
hey we got to stroke and to scratch
under the chin a baby rhino and it was
just this eye and it was it was like a
dog being petted we saw petronella
manager of the orphanage very happily
mingling with these baby rhinos and not
feeling even slightly threatened we were
told they were gonna be sort of herded
up through this long sort of runway I
guess it was like taking toddlers to the
playground they knew what was happening
but we didn't Oh in hang on they are
running at full speed towards me saying
go in you better hurry Darwin Darwin get
out the way and I'm across the way
filming Darwin he leaves it until the
very last second
Oh literally took the door off its
hinges when they came through wood there
are babies but they could do some
serious damage
well like Garwin what are you doing he
was really playing with fire then it was
hilarious after the fact but at the time
it was absolutely terrifying
as it stands right now the war is being
lost
[Music]
since 2007 poaching has increased by
nine thousand percent so let's put that
into perspective
each year was a dramatic increase in the
number of rhinos being poached but we
need to change the attitudes and the
mindset in the Far East before we have
any chance of saving the Rhino
because right now
the poachers are winning right now we're
still at the stage where these
magnificent creatures who've been around
for centuries are now on the brink of
extinction
[Music]
you